ME LOST TO PAT RYAN 3 MONTHS
AGO.
RACE CALLS RIGHT NOW.
>> WE CAN PROJECT THAT THE
MICHIGAN DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR
CRECHE GRETCHEN WHITMER WILL
PREVAIL OVER THE REPUBLICAN
RACE.
DIXON CLOSED THE GAP NEAR THE
END BUT GRETCHEN WHITMER PULLED
IT OUT.
>> AND NEW YORK GOVERNOR KATHY
HOCHUL WILL WIN HER FIRST
FULLTERM IN CONGRESS DEFEATING
LEE ZELDIN.
THERE WERE DEMOCRATS IN THE
STATE SAYING THIS A DONE DEAL
AND ZELDIN WOULD WIN.
KATHY HOCHUL PULLS IT OUT.
SHE BROUGHT IN EVERY LUMMINARY
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
INCLUDING FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND CLINTON AND SECRETARY
CLINTON.
>> I KEEP WONDERING WHAT THE
FLORIDA EFFECT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
ON LEE ZELDIN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE MOVED OUT OF NEW
YORK CITY.
HE HAD TO GET AT LEAST 30%.
1.4 MILLION VOTES IN NEW YORK
CITY.
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN WHERE HE FELL
SHORT.
LOST 50,000 RESIDENTS IN NEW
YORK CITY IN AUGUST ALONE.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE IF
SOME OF THE CLOSING IN FLORIDA
IS PARTLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISGRUNTLED AND LEFT NEW YORK.
>> THAT IN A SECOND.
>> CALLING THE NEBRASKA
GOVERNOR'S RACE FOR THE
REPUBLICAN IN THAT ONE.
>> DANA, THE NEW YORK RACE.
WE COVERED IT CLOSELY.
THE ISSUE OF CRIME MOVED THE
NEEDLE.
NOT ENOUGH TO GET ZELDIN
ELECTED.
IT MIGHT GET NEW YORK
CONGRESSMEN.
>> I HAVE A GOOD FRIEND WHO
WORKS ON DEMOCRATIC HOUSE RACES
AND THEY BELIEVED THEY WERE
GOING TO LOSE ALL OF THE LONG
ISLAND RACES.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS WITH SCHMIDT AND
PAT RYAN.
SCHMIDT IS RIGHT ON HIS HEELS.
LEE ZELDIN WAS ABLE TO GET MEDIA
ATTENTION FOR A REALLY BIG ISSUE
IN NEW YORK.
THAT'S CRIME IN THE CITY.
PART OF WHAT YOU SEE IN LONG
ISLAND AND THE HUDSON VALLEY CAN
S THEY COME INTO NEW YORK TO
WORK.
THE CHILDREN COME HERE TO WORK.
THEY ARE WORRIED.
A SHAME FOR LEE ZELDIN THAT WE
GAVE IT THAT MUCH OF A SHOT.
THERE IS A SENATE RACE THIS
A COUPLE OF YEARS IN NEW YORK.
I THINK I HAVE THAT RIGHT.
HE CAN AT LEAST GET A FOOTHOLD.
HE HAD NEVER RUN IN A STATEWIDE
RACE BEFORE.
MAYBE HE WILL GIVE IT ANOTHER
SHOT.
ANOTHER RACE IN NEW YORK THAT
BILL SHOWED ME.
I LIKED THIS CANDIDATE.
SINGLETARRY.
FORM ARE POLICE CHIEF.
OVER THE WEEKEND HE GOT
A REFUGEE TO GO OUT AND VOTE FOR
HIM.
THEY HAD NEVER VOTED REPUBLICAN
BEFORE BUT ARE WORRIED ABOUT
CRIMES AND WANT A BETTER
EDUCATION FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
>> IN CUSTODY OF POLICE OFFICERS
IN ROCHESTER.
ONE OF THE SUSPECTS WAS
AFFIXIATED AND THE POLICE CHIEF
LOST HIS JOB.
HE IS TRYING TO GET HIS
REPUTATION BACK.
ROCHESTER'S HOMICIDE RATE HIT AN
ALL TIME HIGH.
>> THOSE ARE 2 BIG DEMOCRAT
GOVERNORS WINS.
>> A BIG WIN IN BOAT STATES.
LEE ZELDIN MAY NOT WIN THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE BUT HE IS
KEEPING IT CLOSE ENOUGH AND
CAPITALIZING ON THE ISSUE OF
CRIME IN NEW YORK CITY IN
ROCHESTER AND BUFFALO.
A LOT OF HOUSE RACES THAT
DEMOCRATS HOLD THAT ARE IN
DANGER RIGHT NOW.
THIS REPUBLICANS GET THE HOUSE
AND IT'S DISAPPOINTING FOR HOUSE
REPUBLICANS.
THE MARGIN MAY NUMBER NEW YORK
STATE WHERE REPUBLICANS ARE
DOING WELL.
>> GOOD POINT.
>> FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, WE CAN
SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT MADE
THESE CALLS.
TWEETED OUT A SHOT OF HIM ON THE
PHONE CALLING A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT RACES AND CANDIDATES.
FINISHED WITH THE NUMBERS STAY
IN LINE WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN.
WITH THAT, BRIT, ANY THOUGHTS?
>> WE HAVEN'T CALLED NORTH
CAROLINA YET.
>> WE HAVE NOT.
>> AND OUR WHAT IF SCENARIO, BUD
LOOKS GOOD.
>> WE HAVE ANOTHER GOVERNOR
CALL.
IN MINNESOTA.
TIM WALTZ WILL WIN THAT.
ANOTHER BIG WIN FOR DEMOCRATS.
THIS WAS MORE PROJECTED FROM THE
BEGINNING.
TIM WALTZ WILL BEAT THE
REPUBLICAN JENSEN IN THAT RACE
FROM MINNESOTA.
THE GOVERNORS RACES A NUMBER OF
THEM OUT WEST THAT REPUBLICANS
ARE LOOKING FOR INCLUDING
ARIZONA WITH KARI LAKE AND THERE
IS A LOT COMING IN AS FAR AS RAW
VOTES TOTAL BUT TOO EARLY TO
CALL.
>> AND OREGON AS WELL.
THE NIGHT IS FAR FROM OVER.
WE ARE COUNTING DOWN TO THE NEXT
POLL CLOSI